If there is a single force as a
biologist,
I would have to begin with the force of
evolution.
Uh,
clearly,
uh,
I believe in evolution.
I believe in the,
in the theory of natural selection.
I think it's had an enormous impact on
who we are as a species and where we are
today.
Um,
I believe in the power of technology.
I think particularly if you look at the
history of human endeavor,
you could write that history based on
the kinds of technological advances we
know from the bronze age on the first
time someone picked up a stick and
realized it could be a tool,
uh,
to what is happening today in,
with the Internet,
for example.
I think that has been a tremendous,
tremendous,
uh,
force,
that has affected the way we have
developed as a species.
Um,
I think the other would be the move away
from subsistence to creating excess,
which is another way of saying,
uh,
the ability to move from living hand to
mouth to find the leak creating wealth
than what wealth allowed individuals to
do,
uh,
both in terms of creating a greater
comfort in the way we live.
But I think also in allowing us to
leisure time that allows us as humans to
create art,
for example.
I think the great force in higher
education in the United States has been
a,
is really been several things actually,
now that I think about it.
The first I think was the commitment
really from the very beginning of this
country to free public education.
Um,
that I think was a revolutionary idea in
some respects.
And I think it is one that has served
the country very well until relatively
recent times.
And I think if I have one concern about
how that is now playing out today in
2007,
uh,
I worry about the enormous difference in
the quality of the very best and the
very worst of our public schools in this
country.
Uh,
the gap between what happens in
Princeton high school and what happens
in the high schools in Trenton,
which are just 20 miles away,
are night and day.
And I worry about the degree to which
are striving for free public education
has really been diminished in this
country.
Uh,
I think the same thing could be true
about great state universities.
They,
they were created a so that at every
individual capable of doing work at the
university level,
what have an opportunity to go to
college.
Uh,
as those state colleges and universities
are being financially squeezed by their
state legislatures,
they have only one choice and that is to
raise tuition.
And as they've raised tuition,
those state colleges and universities
become less and less accessible to those
who are in the bottom of the income
bracket.